merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
au moment où notre pays vient d'être
livré au saccage au pillage et à une
rage incendiaire insensé je voudrais
vous poser la question que se pose tous
les Français qu'avez-vous fait de la
France vous qui mener la même politique
que vous prédécesseurs depuis 40 ans
qu'avez-vous fait de notre pays en y
implantant des zones de non-droit que
vous avez laissé ce communautariser ce
criminaliser qu'avez-vous fait lorsque
vous avez laissé prospérer l'ignorance
de notre culture l'hostilité à l'égard
de l'autorité légale de l'état
l'illégittimité de nos lois et la haine
de notre peuple qu'avez-vous fait pour
transformer notre pays parmi les plus
courtois les plus élégants et les plus
doux de la terre pour en faire un enfer
ou ce conçu avec les bâtiments publics
qui brûlent toutefois en l'avenir
ce spectacle afflige le monde entier et
notre pays qui fut tant admirer pour son
rayonnement intellectuel et sa puissance
suscite aujourd'hui la pitié quand ce
n'est pas l'ironie vous n'avez tiré
aucune leçon des émeutes de 2005 pas
plus du Stade de France qui laisse
augurer un désastre sécurité pour les JO
de 2024 et avec lui une nouvelle
humiliation nationale la vérité c'est
que vous n'avez voulu entendre aucun
avertissement ce qui arrive nous
l'avions prédit malgré une grande
adversité je le dis avec tristesse et
gravité nous avons eu malheureusement
raison au moment où vous vous apprêtez à
nous resservir un coup de milliard à
énième plomb banlieue je vous appelle au
courage de l'autocritique à l'humilité
d'admettre l'échec dramatique de vos
politiques il faut d'abord et avant tout
stopper l'immigration anarchique or vous
êtes en train d'aggraver le problème du
communautarisme voire du séparatisme et
de le disséminer dans le moindre village
il faut ensuite reprendre la main dans
tous les quartiers de France rétablir
l'autorité des parents refaire de
l'école le creuset de la République
rendre à la justice sa fermeté sans
laquelle elle restera impuissante à
protéger les Français merci beaucoup
économique et judiciaire merci
possible la nationale
la parole est à Madame Elisabeth borne
première ministre
[Musique]
madame la première minute
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la Présidente Le Pen alors oui madame la
Présidente j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'intention votre intervention et j'ai
cru un instant qui pourrait y avoir des
propositions mais jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
bout vous devez montrer une fois de plus
la seule chose dont vous êtes capable
c'est la caricature et vous voyez madame
la Présidente je regrette même si ça ne
me surprend pas beaucoup que le choix
que vous faites c'est celui de la
division et quand j'entends le président
de votre partie opposée les territoires
ruraux et les quartiers comme si aider
les uns devaient dépouiller les autres
je me dis décidément vous n'avez pas
changé et quand j'entends encore à
l'instant pointé certaines parties de
notre population je me dis de nouveau
les caricatures vraiment vous n'y
échapperez pas je pense que aujourd'hui
alors que notre pays alors que de
nombreux maires vivent des situations
difficiles alors que commerçants et des
artisans on fait face à beaucoup de
violences ne pas jouer l'unité du pays
c'est ce n'est pas responsable madame la
Présidente Le Pen ça n'est pas
responsable
alors voyez pour notre part nous serons
toujours au soutien de nos policiers de
nos gendarmes de nos sapeurs-pompiers
des policiers municipaux des élus locaux
et nous serons tous toujours mobilisés
pour lutter contre la violence mais nous
sommes également mobilisés pour lutter
contre le poison de la division et quand
notre République est attaqué c'est
l'unité nationale qui doit l'emporter je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre